how do you learn all those pages of
dialogue every day you're working
constantly law in order you're not doing
like Eight Episodes a year on a
streaming show you were doing how many
episodes 22 to 23 yeah how did you I
know I mean how how did you deal with
that well I would stage three scripts
ahead is I I only had one choice I can
only do that there's the only way so so
I was giving notes on one script that I
had just
read um the other script uh the the
second script I would be um trying to
figure out how I could actually what how
to control my arc in it and then the
third one would be the one that we were
performing at the time and I was
learning and I was learning
scenes I would stay two days ahead of
scenes and still be studying while I'm
performing other scenes so it was like a
lot of work you know yeah because you
had a you had exhaustion you collapsed
on set like in 2004 right yeah I mean
did you know that this did you feel like
this is going to happen like my body
can't take this anymore I'm so
tired did you feel it or did it just
happen how did what
happened
um I just couldn't believe that we were
working so much I just couldn't believe
that that it was okay to do year after
year and um you know I learned the hard
way that it was okay that that's the way
the business was and it's not like that
anymore the New York Times did an
article about the hours the tele
television hours and Kate and I were you
know a main part of that that article
like because we were at the time
averaging 16 17 hours a
day and that that that you know that
they said that in that article like so
it's
like um but you know it's like today
these days it's like a
vacation I mean honestly Nine episod
Nine episodes a season yeah you
know you know granted in and network
television you make tons more money but
in the end it ain't worth it yeah that's
the thing I mean you do sell your soul
in a way you're like yeah you're risking
your health nasty you get nasty I was I
was you know I got to the point where I
was
completely um in my head and and and
just had no patience for for any
anything anything you know like the only
people that I would give back to were
the other actors and and and the camera
crew everybody else to me was just in my
way and taking up my time from getting
home and going to sleep wow yeah did
they ever have a conversation with you
about no but I have to say though having
said all that when I left that show I
was 10 times a better actor than I was
before I went on it
wow what why is that why is that is it
the intensity and all that combined just
my chops got so good like I was just my
chops I I learned how to transition so
much easier you know I was just used to
doing film where you you do story
transition transitions or emotional
transitions over like three scenes or an
act you know but on television you do
transitions within a scene you know big
ones yeah and so to be able to pull that
off was you know it I I think it does
with everybody it it it you either it
either makes you or breaks you and you
either end up um coming in and doing one
line cut one line cut one line cut which
a lot of people end up doing or you
master it and you become this like
machine yeah everybody does obviously
not just me and um and you leave at some
a situation like that like you know
you're
you're you're great at at the technical
aspect of your job